The next tool we're going to talk about is the Variant Manager.
We'll do a quick take on this and show you exactly how to get started with it and how
many cool things you can do with it to really help with your production and to be able to
help some of the people such as your art director or your director decide where they want to
place things in the world quickly and easily.
So one of the reasons to use it is to manage multiple assets at the same time with changes.
This can include rotation, scale, movement, color and multiple different aspects of this
object.
And you'll see that list when I pull it up.
It's really a lot to name but you'll see that you really have a lot of control with this
tool.
One thing before we get started I want to mention is you have to be aware that if you
are moving assets around in a virtual production that your light needs to be movable in some
way.
And that way if you are moving things around you don't necessarily have to do a full bake.
So if it's movable, if you add an asset or change an asset, Unreal won't get confused
with your shadows and that movable light can update on the fly.
This can also be set with ray tracing but again your systems need to support that efficiently
and for the highest quality that you can get.
Alright so let's actually look at what we can do.
One of the first things we want to do is go to miscellaneous and then we want to set in
a level variant set.
And that's what we're going to do right now.
So in here I just have a blank scene.
I just pulled in a house from our structures folder.
Just slap that in here.
And I'm going to go in here and just right click and I'll just do it here for now and
that's fine.
I'm going to go in here and go to my miscellaneous tab.
In my miscellaneous tab we're going to go to our level variant sets and open that up.
We'll call this level variant so LV underscore house set 01 and we'll double click on it.
In here we want to click on the variant set.
So this is going to give us our first set.
This is basically kind of a grouping method.
It's going to now be ready to be populated.
And I'm going to hit the plus button and in here this will make us our new variant.
Now you can also just right click and say hey man let's add a variant or you can just
hit that add button and that makes your life easier.
With this object selected in our scene I easily just go in here right click and add selected
actors.
This could be multiple actors or just one or whatever you choose you can add the actor
here.
Now you'll see instantly when I add that actor we have so many different things that we can
choose from to be able to actually change this actor on the fly.
If you want to change the material if you want to change mobility all these things are
in here is a dynamic or not all these things are available in here which is really really
convenient.
It's specifically if you need to change positioning on an object or material quickly you can actually
and the art director be able to see the changes suggested and what is available at their fingertips
to be able to get the scenes that they need and want.
So in here what we're going to be messing with is mainly the relative location the relative
rotation and the relative scale.
That's mainly what we're going to be messing with here.
So we make sure we have those active.
Now this is going to make it so that our static mesh we can control its positioning anywhere.
We can choose material and a few others but we won't go through all of these.
They're pretty straightforward.
So I'm going to hit select.
Now this object in our 3D space with it selected I can go in here and just you know try to
place it and put it in the right spot.
Now what happens is a recording feature happens.
You see this little dot active.
If I move this around get this in the right spot that I need and I can click on this and
you'll now see a little on the whole set of our regular translation rotation and scale
that shows up in details will populate here.
Sometimes it'll need a little refresh.
You'll notice I clicked on it moved around a little bit click on it again.
It'll pop up.
So now that it's populated I can keep this in here.
It's going to record that positioning but maybe I want to show the director a different
type of position for this.
So I can right click in here and duplicate that object and control W will do the same.
And in here I now have this same geometry I double clicked on it active in this slot
here and I can choose that position.
I can move this position.
I can rotate it just a tad and I can hit these two recording of those changes here.
You'll see a little arrow with a flat kind of rectangular white icon pointing to it.
So record that and record that change.
So now when your director looks at your stage and says hey man that looks great but you
been talking to the storyboard artist the concept artist and there's a few different
things he wasn't maybe he couldn't quite make his decision on the art director or the
director and you can now show them the switching between these.
So I can click on this position that we've already have set in the defaults and then
the new one that we rotated and we can keep duplicating these.
We can keep making more with different positioning and this is allowing me to shuffle between
these and this is what I meant by making sure that your light is movable for the fact that
your shadow won't have to be set and you have to marry to a particular positioning of your
shadow you'll just have that movable so as you flip through these different pieces of
the model you're not going to have to re-bake every single time.
Those are things to keep in mind when using this tool.
You can see quickly we're switching between these and again this can be through material
this can be all sorts of different dependencies in here and you saw the full list that you
can do and this makes the variant manager really powerful and really great especially
if you want to be able to show different varieties of layout and set dressing for a virtual production.